das heißt wir haben jetzt diese drei
sachen für ungefähr 5000 euro
drei produkte eine tasche in schal und
einen pulli für 5000 euro muss man auch
erstmal sacken lassen mal die kleinen
reich steps und die wird auch sofort
kaputt
das war es ohne witz ich hatte in dem
elbe stellt das ist es etwas gedauert
jetzt willkommen bei einem neuen video
ja leute ich hoffe natürlich ganz gut
bevor dieses wieder losgeht wollte ich
noch zwei wichtige ankündigung machen
und zwar gibt es jetzt immer am montag
und am mittwoch ein video um 19 uhr und
am freitag und am sonntag ein video um
14 uhr also merkt euch am besten einfach
diese daten und ja da gibt es jetzt halt
immer videos also einen kleinen upload
planen damit ich es für mich selber halt
auch wenn ich da hat nur noch eine
andere sache ich werde in letzter zeit
immer öfter gefragt woher ich die
klamotten habe die ich in meinen videos
trage zum beispiel diesen cup holly oder
so ich werde euch immer den link dazu in
die beschreibung packen also in jedem
video die sachen die ich tragen werde
für einen pulli steht heute in der
beschreibung das heißt wenn ihr nicht
könnt ihr euch in der beschreibung link
anschauen und durch den gegebenfalls
keine ahnung wünschen oder selber kaufen
was auch immer darum geht es heute aber
gar nicht es geht heute nach so langer
zeit um die louis vitton fake produkte
die endlich mal angekommen sind leute
ihr könnt euch nicht vorstellen wie
lange das gedauert hat dieser politik er
kam vor ungefähr einer woche und das
video
und das liege dazu habe ich vor
keine ahnung ich schaue mal kurz nach
das video kam von zweieinhalb monaten
das heißt er hat zweieinhalb monate
gebraucht eigentlich wollte ich da wo es
ursprünglich ein neues format machen
dass ich halt so fade produkte testen
wie louis vitton supreme und so weiter
ist halt nur sehr schwierig wenn das
immer so lange dauert ja wir machen uns
heute allerdings so ich werde euch die
produkte einfach mal zeigen es sind drei
produkte angekommen wir machen den
kleinen test inwiefern die gut
produziert sind oder schlecht allzu
sachen wie qualität aussehen das checken
wir heute mal so ein bisschen
vergleichen das auch mit dem original
wobei ich das original natürlich nicht
gehabt sonst wäre ich jetzt um 10.000
erwartet ungefähr 12.000 euro ärmer was
aber noch ganz wichtig ist zu sagen
leute ich möchte mit diesem video
natürlich keine fakes unterstützten fake
sind scheiße ich will auch nicht dass
ihr euch jetzt hier auch so ein fake
politik stellt wobei ich angenommen
dieser police jetzt gut verstehen kann
wenn man sich den hier für 12 euro holt
anstatt das original für 10.000 das
möchte ich jetzt nämlich sehr gerne
einmal kurz ab checken und zwar
interessiert mich wo dieser pole gerade
preis liegt wie schon gesagt ich habe
den für 12 euro gekauft wo ist ja
scheißegal aber fast nur auf louis
vitton extreme holy genau ich meine
nämlich ich hatte mal für 10.000 gesehen
okay da nehme ich jetzt einiges zurück
doch nicht 10.000 obwohl wir haben ja
vielleicht habe ich auch nur geträumt
aber kann gut sein dass da immer so hoch
gehandelt wurde also wir haben ja diesen
pulli für 3950 euro sieht eigentlich
original aus hier auf den fotos sind
hier noch mal für mal 5000 schweizer
franken also ungefähr 4000 euro für ein
pulli ist ja komplett gestört wer kauft
sich für 4000 euro ein pulli als
nächstes haben wir hier noch diesen
louis vitton schal in blau der auf mich
erst mal einen wirklich guten eindruck
gemacht hat wir nehmen ihn gleich mal
ein bisschen genauer unter die lupe habe
ich für zehn euro bekommen und wir haben
hier noch diese louis vuitton tasche hat
sich die große tasche die fast alle
girls heutzutage haben sondern
so ein kleines ding was glaube ich sogar
bei manchen großen taschen dabei das
habe ich glaube ich letztens im shop
gefunden hat glaube ich 600 euro kostet
aber sofort nochmal nach habe ich jetzt
für sechs euro für 90 glaube ich gekauft
das ding war als allererstes darf schon
auf zwei wochen oder nicht mag und lag
jetzt einfach zwei monate ruhen sohn
louis vitton schallt das weiß ich
eigentlich kostet um die 400 euro kommt
ganz drauf an was für ein modell
ich weiß jetzt nicht ob man das ungefähr
haben ich habe auf jeden fall auch schon
mal so ein ding gekauft und grau für 400
euro warum scheißegal der leute ich habe
gerade hier noch die andere tasche
gesucht finde ich nicht wir stufen jetzt
einfach mal für 600 euro in dieses
kleinen dingen originalpreis wird
schreibt gerne in die kommentare
das heißt wir haben jetzt diese drei
sachen für ungefähr 5000 euro drei
produkte eine taschen schuhe und einen
pulli für 5000 euro muss man auch
erstmal sacken lassen die 11.000 euro da
weiß ich gesagt habe am anfang wenig
wieder zurück ich bin davon ausging der
pulli war wirklich bei 10.000 ja ich
will gar nicht lange lagern wir gehen
über zum test wie steht ihm das ganze
vergleichen das ein bisschen mit den
original produkten und ich bin gespannt
ja also let's go so ich würde sagen
anfang an mit der tasche die sieht so
aus von namen
ich kann sie ja einfach drehen
wahrscheinlich fallen jetzt den louis
vitton experten von euch sofort einige
fehler also von der tasche bin ich auch
nicht wirklich begeistert wobei man
sagen kann dass wenn man hier das muster
so von weitem betrachtet ist es
eigentlich gleich wie beim original ich
kann euch gerne kurzen tote von der
originalen tasche einblenden
also das sieht ähnlich aus wenn man
jetzt aber genauer hinguckt und einmal
ein blick hinein macht hat das
eigentlich wenig mit einem originalen
produkt zu tun ich will gar nicht sagen
dass wir uns hier von außen an der
qualität sofort merkt aber wenn man
reinschaut und mal rein führt das fühlt
sich auf keinen fall nach auch das ist
das keine ahnung fällt wenigstens
normalerweise hat man hier drin aus und
vitor muster das ist hier halt nicht der
fall auch die reißverschlüsse wird nur
qualitativ schlecht und auch von der
nadja ist das nicht gut verarbeitet mal
den kleinen reichstag und die wird auch
sofort kaputt
das war es aber leute ganz wichtig für
die die jetzt sagen er alex was
erwartest du nicht mein das ding hat
sieben euro gekostet klar das kann ja
auch nicht sein das ist natürlich klar
nur man darf dabei natürlich auch nicht
vergessen dass so eine louis vuitton
tasche in der produktion jetzt sicher
nicht nur sieben euro kostet aber ich
würde dir jetzt auch nicht unbedingt auf
mehr als 30 oder 40 euro einstufen das
ist dann einfach die marke die diesen
preis macht und deswegen passiert ist
auch ganz so ich habe letztens mal einen
beitrag dazu gesehen das halt so marken
wie louis vitton erhalt sage ich mal
10.000 von so taschen ordern davon aber
nur 9000 gebraucht werden um die 1000
die über bleiben sind an sich natürlich
originale taschen die dann auf
irgendwelchen komischen märkten für
weniger verkauft werden also an sich ist
halt nur die marke die diesen hohen
preis machthaber diese tasche kann man
eigentlich sofort wieder möglich machen
so kommen wir als nächstes zum schal wir
haben wir diesen blauen die torzahl für
zehn euro von dem bin ich eigentlich
positiv überrascht ich weiß nicht wie
sie auf der kamera aussieht aber wenn
man das jetzt von namen betrachtet kann
man sagen dass diese logos hier halt zum
beispiel hier die sind nicht wie beim
original so ein bisschen drauf gesteckt
sondern einfach ein genäht wird aber nur
wirklich auch wenn man das nach vor
augen hat ich habe jetzt nicht jedes
modell genau studiert aber auch die
schrift hillary vitor lässt sich bei dem
schade denn ich mal gekauft habe ähnlich
wiederfinden nur nicht ganz so groß ob
es jetzt wirklich einen schal gift bei
dem wir so groß ist das weiß ich nicht
habe ich leider auch nicht recherchieren
können
trotzdem gefällt mir die qualität
eigentlich ganz gut wenn man mal dran
reist passiert auch nicht das einzige
was ja auch nicht gut verarbeitet ist
ist die naht
das ist im original ein bisschen besser
mal kurz ein bild von einem originalen
schal da sieht man halt jetzt zum
beispiel rund um diese fransen und was
habe ich ganz klar zu erkennen ist die
louis vitton logos auf dem schal sind
halt viel besser verarbeitet die sind
ein bisschen aufgestickt die lenzen und
bisschen stechen heraus habe ich am
anfang schon gesagt dass es bei diesem
hier nicht so als abschließend kann man
auch hier sagen
weiter weg ist es schwer einen
unterschied zu erkennen wenn man das
dann aber genauer unter die lupe nimmt
ganz klar viele unterschiede deswegen
auch hier nicht wirklich zu empfehlen
wobei ich am anfang auch gesagt habt
kauft keine fällig so leicht und jetzt
bin ich eigentlich am meisten gespannt
auf den pulli weil den habe ich noch gar
nicht ausgepackt
so lächelt jetzt bin ich und jetzt bin
ich mal gespannt wie ist das denn hier
die auftritte haben sich irgendwie ein
bisschen ineinander
schaut man hört ihr das dieses voll
zusammengeklebt alter was hab ich auch
noch nie gesehen wahrscheinlich weil da
seit dem druck drei monate drin lag ja
schon mal ganz klar zu erkennen dass
louis victor hugo und hier das supreme
logo drauf alter das ist wirklich
katastrophen er schaut euch das an ich
weiß nicht wie es jetzt in der kamera
aussieht aber wenn man drüber geht
es stinkt auch hier drin also das stoff
ist wirklich wahr wenn man da drüber
geht da merkt man richtig das ist
richtig schlechte qualität aber es sind
ja eben auch felix wobei auch hier haben
wir sogar ein schild dran
louis vitton originals ach so und hier
diese bändchen das geht da einfach raus
da ist nicht mal irgendwie was
festgemacht oder so also ich glaube das
ist bis jetzt das schlechteste produkt
da wird sich in der produktion wirklich
überhaupt keine mühe gemacht ich habe
mir eben gesagt in der produktion kostet
auf der politik man jetzt für 4000 euro
kaufen kann in der produktion
ich würde mal sagen wegen den ganzen
drucken ich habe selber lange klamotten
marke
mitgeführt vielleicht weil es ein
qualitativer pulli ist das trio so gut
drauf gesteckt ist maximal 30 euro und
der hat jetzt meine ich 12 kostet
maximal 15 aber ich glaube es war gut
ich ziehe den mal kurz an 40 hat den
elbe stellt das ist es also leute schaut
sich an so sieht das aus ich sehe aus
wie in so eine zwangs anzug weil der
wirklich brutal eng ist da geht auch nur
bis hier unten also hier würde ich
wirklich sagen das ist das schlechteste
produkt von allen wahrscheinlich kann
man das hier sofort abreißen na ja das
waren jetzt drei produkte im test ich
würde sagen natürlich muss ich mich kurz
vorstellen wenn ihr sagt alex das hat
mir gefallen macht das doch bitte mal
mit der un der marke dann schreib es auf
jeden fall jetzt in die kommentare und
lassen noch nach oben da dann kann ich
eventuell noch mal ein paar machen
vielleicht geht das dann noch ein
bisschen schöner mit dem versand muss
ich halt sofort drauf schauen ich hoffe
es hat euch gefallen
lasst die finger weg von fakes und
vielleicht haben wir ja beim nächsten
mal ein bisschen mehr erfolg für
qualitative fake leistung wir werden
sehen morgen gibt es ein neues video um
19 uhr habe ich dann gesagt also leute
haut rein absolut noch ganz wichtig wenn
ihr sagt ey du findest in pully zwar
scheiße aber so ein pulli wollte ich
schon immer und an den originalen komme
ich nicht
ich meine ich würde es sonst
wahrscheinlich eh wegschmeißen schreibt
man gerne in die kommentare einfach
irgendeine zahl zwischen 1 und 1000 ich
habe ein imker und werde am nächsten
dran ist oder die zahl trifft dann
schreibe ich an den krieg den pulli mit
eurem instagram lahm bitte damit ich
euch nachher finden kann ihr könnt mir
die zahl auch gerne sonst direkt schon
über instagram schicken einfach alex wie
auf instagram eingeben zahlt schicken
und vielleicht gewinnt ihr das gleiche
gilt natürlich auch für den schal und
die tasche
der schal ist eigentlich ganz okay